okay before we get started with this
video I had one little announcement to
make but I forgot what it was oh yeah as
you can see we have reached 10,000
subscribers on the Lange focus channel
thank you for helping me reach 10,000
let's keep it going let's hit fifty
thousand a hundred thousand let's see
how big this gets but you guys are the
original crew thank you for your support
from day one so let's get into today's
topic I'm going to talk about the
Persian language it's sometimes known as
Farsi but I'm going to call it Persian
Persian is a language that is widely
spoken in parts of the Middle East and
in Central Asia and it has a long
history stretching back thousands of
years with a few different stages along
the way the Persian language originated
in southwestern Persia wait I don't see
Persia on this map right here oh that's
right
today Persia is known as Iran Persian is
the one official language of Iran and it
is the native language of about half of
Iranians the statistics actually range
from about 45 to 55 percent but I'm
going to say half and that makes it
thirty-eight point five million people
but virtually all other Iranians can
speak Persian as a second language as
well Persian is also an official
language in two other countries but you
might not know that because they refer
to the language by different names in
those places in Afghanistan the language
is referred to as dari for political
reasons but speakers of dari Persian
themselves often call their language
Farsi it's actually really hard to get
reliable statistics about Afghanistan
but most sources seem to say that it is
spoken by twenty-five to thirty percent
of the population in Afghanistan but it
is also widely used as a lingua franca
and pretty much everyone in the country
can speak dari
in Tajikistan Persian is referred to as
Tajik because that's what the Soviet
Union conquerors decided to call it you
know how foreign empires like to divide
and conquer
no no don't be friends with that
powerful country over there no no no
you're separate you're distinct from
them but Tajik Persian is indeed a
variety of Persian it is spoken by six
million people in Tajikistan and another
1.5 million people in the nearby Central
Asian countries especially in
person is also spoken by about 5 million
expatriates around the world especially
in some middle-east countries like Iraq
UAE Bahrain places like that as well as
the USA so let's recap in Iran there are
about thirty eight point five million
native speakers of Persian in
Afghanistan and Pakistan there are 11
million native speakers of dari Persian
in Tajikistan and surrounding areas
there are 7.5 million native speakers of
Tajik Persian and there are about 5
million expat speaking Persian around
the world that comes to a total of 62
million native speakers but if we
include all the second language speakers
of Persian who use it as a lingua franca
then the number rises to 110 million
speakers around the world our persian
dari and Tajik all really the same
language yes they are varieties of one
single language they are mutually
intelligible especially among educated
speakers and the formal languages are
very close to each other there are some
differences in the casual language
especially in the accent and some of the
vocabulary that's used some of the
spelling things like that but basically
they are one language and they are
mutually intelligible one difference
that I often come across is the lone
words in the different varieties so in
Iran there are more French loanwords in
Afghanistan there are more English
loanwords and in Tajikistan there are
more Russian loanwords some people who
are not so familiar with the Persian
language might assume that it's related
to the Arabic language because Iran is
in the Middle East and is next to Iraq
but actually Persian is in a totally
different language family than the
Arabic language it is in the
indo-european language family that means
that Persian shares historical origins
with most of the languages in Europe
including English as well as the
languages of northern India and most
speakers of indo-european languages find
Persian much easier to learn that Arabic
because of the grammatical similarity
but it does look like Arabic because for
historical reasons Persian is usually
written in the Arabic script except in
Tajikistan let's look at the history
first there was old Persian the oldest
known records of old Persian or in
inscriptions dating back to the first
Persian Empire these writings are
written in Babylonian cuneiform script
which is one of the oldest writing forms
in the world we have writings like this
from various places that were part of
the first Persian Empire including
Iran of course but also Romania Armenia
Iraq Bahrain Turkey and Egypt next there
was middle Persian from about 300 BCE
until about 800 seee old persian
developed into middle Persian which is
also known as Pallavi we can find middle
Persian mainly in religious texts of the
Zoroastrian religion from before the
Islamic period the language was referred
to as parsing or parsec during this time
period because it was the language of
the Parsa people the Persian language
entered a mysterious new stage with the
Islamic conquest in 651 ad the following
200 years are referred to by Iranian
scholars as two centuries of silence
because there is very little almost no
literature available from that time
period we don't know exactly why but
it's possible that it was forbidden to
write in the Persian language by the
Arab rulers these two centuries of
silence are a kind of transition period
from middle Persian to modern Persian
and Persian was affected by the Arabic
language quite a lot during this time
that brings us to modern Persian or new
Persian around 800 C II the Persian
language was in danger of being lost and
replaced by Arabic but Persia was one of
the few places where the Arabic language
did not replace the local language
however Arabic was used by the
intellectuals and by the elite and it
definitely had a big impact on the
vocabulary of the modern Persian that
was emerging after the end of Arab rule
in Persia in the 9th century the Persian
language and culture was once again
reinvigorated and a new period of
classic literature and poetry arose one
important piece of literature was
firdaus EES shahnameh the book of kings
which is the longest work of epic poetry
ever written
it was so influential on future
literature and cultural identity that
the Persian language today remains
relatively unchanged from that time this
one epic poem is a sort of pillar of the
Persian language it is said that
ferdowsi intentionally limited the
number of Arabic loanwords used in his
epic poem in order to help preserve the
integrity of the Persian language of
course there still are a significant
number of Arabic words in Persian but
not as many as there could have been
during this Persian cultural resurgence
the Persian language and culture
impacted a wide geographic area Persian
became the official language of the
Seljuk Empire extending into present-day
Turkey and later was the first official
language of the Ottoman Empire
Turkish later became the official
language of the Ottoman Empire but its
vocabulary had been very influenced by
Arabic and Persian Persian also spread
to the Indian subcontinent where it was
widely spoken until the arrival of the
British Persian has left its influence
on a lot of different languages
including a heavy influence on the
vocabulary of Perdue and also some
influence on the vocabulary of Turkish
but you can find words of Persian origin
in languages as far away as the Malay
language in Malaysia and of course there
are English words that are of Persian
origin some of them came directly into
English from Persian but most of them
came in directly into English via a
different language bizarre bronze jackal
kiosk lemon mogul mummy pyjama Scarlett
serendipity shawl tulip turban typhoon
khaki Caravan paradise the word
checkmate actually comes from shammed
which means the king is dead and maybe
tiger though that one is disputed
learning persian is a great idea because
you will be able to speak with a hundred
and ten million Persian speakers around
the world but it also gives you access
to a rich history of literature and
insight into a culture that has had a
big impact on the world and if you ever
decide to learn Arabic in the future
after learning Persian then you'll
already know a lot of Arabic words from
Persia thank you for watching the lang
focused channel I hope that was
educational if you have any comments
write them down below and have a nice
day